that's now 1951 okay I see the bomb I'm
in I'm in the basement okay it's chicken
down all right all right we have
illuminated sign symbol right want to
start with those to it okay we have one
that looks like a pod [ __ ] I don't know
how to pee backwards that's filled in a
little bit of blacking okay okay press
the you said there was one I look like a
six and I trust you yes this is this is
real this time for a real princess
physics it got green off and Ghana Chris
Tempe I'm pressing the P Krista K I'm
pressing up cash the question work we
did it we did it
alright go number one yellow number two
blue okay hold on G calm okay crying
hold on hold on
cry if I die here yes I want you to take
care of my tear for me uh not gonna
happen
don't worry about we have we have a bomb
to defuse right now okay so I'm waiting
for your instructions hello okay why is
what are you looking at comes your
second wire the second wire the second
wire cried yes Yogi's is from the top
down just cook the second Warrior I
forgot my pliers
[ __ ] I'll just tear it tear it it worked
Jessica huh except pen sorry
no no it didn't work it didn't work it
didn't work I got words oh god oh god oh
god we got it wait I I did it but
there's something missing there's
something missing there's something
missing uh there's there's I got a
serial number cut the pot lawyer the
person for you yes oh god we got another
strike right we're all right
Am I oh [ __ ] house freezing the wrong
one oh no um so [ __ ] I we can't make any
more mistakes
all right he said there's a red wire no
for I got the first one already
personally Jen
all right I left what I what I pull out
that